girl dang that was that was deep
that was documentary
[Music]
hello I'm Hannah Hart and welcome to
edible history the show where we Revere
the foods of yesteryear today we're
serving up a southern staple as we
explore the history of Jam Valaya when I
think of jambalaya I think of a savory
rice and seafood dish with a bit of a
Creole kick but is that really how this
dish got it start to get the scoop on
Jam balaiah I'm talking with Michael
Twitty author of the 2018 James Beard
Foundation Book of the Year the cooking
gene a journey through African American
culinary history in the Old South can
you tell me a little bit about your
background as a culinary historian the
culinary history is the history of how
we cook my job is to interpret the food
ways of free people of color and
enslaved people in the colonial and
antebellum period I want people to see
in living color our tradition is ancient
our tradition is multicultural and I'm
extremely proud of that some of those
recipes have come down to each of us in
our households so today we're gonna be
exploring the history behind jambalaya
yeah let me tell you everything I know
jambalaya just got rice in it Creole
cuisine maybe it's its southern and
that's it
all of those things are jambalaya for me
is very Creole over occasion I think of
a really delicious one pot rice meal not
quite wet not quite dry some people
think that black food is very provincial
rural agrarian comfort food it's much
more complicated than that because it's
also a part of a global phenomenon we
call the African Diaspora in the
Caribbean in Louisiana in South Carolina
and Brazil and Haiti there are all these
different rice dishes so they could be
as simple as peas and rice rice was not
indigenous to the new world and so rice
alone with plantains and bananas are
brought from the African continent and
wherever against lay people are
disembarked to work on plantations that
are mines those become staple foods so
how did jambalaya become popular across
the rest of America not just the south
through migration the great migration
was the largest freewill migration of
Americans in American history and that
was African Americans leaving the South
going other places so for the jambul I
were gonna be making today where does
that recipe come from it comes from a
beautiful woman named Abby Fisher and
Abby Fisher was illiterate but she
produced one of the first black
books published by the women's
cooperative so she is born in Orangeburg
South Carolina she spent some time in
Mobile Alabama which has a much more
creole heritage and then she ends up in
San Francisco
Abby Fisher's Jim Burley is probably
from her experience in Mobile so how is
this recipe different from the jambalaya
we think of today this is more of a
southern precursor to that dish and it's
also very implementing of those tomato
based rice and protein dishes that are
symbolic of the link between Africa of
the Caribbean Afro Latin America and the
American South bringing together all the
different cultures Wow so Jan balaiah is
quite literally a melting pot literally
literally thank you for sharing this
history with me let's put this history
in our mouth yeah yeah let's cook okay
[Music]
today Michael our expert is actually
joining me in our edible history kitchen
so today's recipe comes from Abby
Fisher's cookbook what mrs. Fisher knows
about old southern cooking from the Year
1881 so Michael would you please read
the first step take one chicken and cut
it up separating every joint and adding
it to one pint of cleanly washed rice
dad no don't make the girl don't play
with your food
sorry yeah
come here little chicken thank you for
your service Oh God okay here we go
perfect
yeah yeah there okay you can do this
next part oh you're gonna break it in
half sweet mother of God look at her go
so then we go like that look at them
bones I can see why people just twist it
off yeah there we go
yes there it is okay so I'll take this
piece and toss it in the pot okay so
next is the thigh I've never seen
somebody disassemble a chicken Paillard
now I can cut I can do it okay this
little way to teach me how to do the
wing kind of like at this edge right
here mm-hmm and make it loose first make
it loose okay cut where there's a little
bit of freedom oh okay oh I found it I
found the joint around it yep yep
where's nice and soft yeah oh there we
go and Link plot so what add the rice
cool move that of the race
step one is done we've got our chicken
we've got our rice now it's time for us
to go and clean everything before you
come back for step number two our next
step reads take about a half dozen large
Tomatoes scalding them well and taking
the skins off with a knife Michael what
does that mean so it basically means
we're going to use boiling water
Judy skinned the tomatoes and the first
thing we're gonna do actually to help
the process so do it like a nice deep X
and then what I'd like you to do is core
the tomato Wow Wow
how'd you get it turn turn turn turn
turn turn turn
oh yeah we got it Shaboom so we got to
get these in there great
using this yep very safely your three
first do three mm-hmm okay here we go
all right we let those do their little
dance little water dance and we're gonna
just let them go for about 45 seconds or
so okay now take a mat one at a time oh
sorry madam mm-hmm place them in the ice
bath yes
now you gotta go DS guys okay okay do
you want one of these now so let me give
me one second test it oh that's perfect
that magic oh wow okay now will you walk
me through what Justin yes so just peel
the tomato from the bottom it looks like
a love Apple doesn't it oh it does
usually called love Emma's love Apple so
at the bottom peel oh wow
this comes off beautifully I've never
done this to a tomato I've always
thought that stewed tomatoes just
exclusively come from kin gentle gentle
gentle yeah beautiful so now that we've
gotten our tomatoes peeled yep it's time
to slice them yep just like this and we
want to do in half and half okay so we
just toss them in there yep I've got
another one how about this I'll peel and
you cut yes ma'am
sir for you there you go thank you thank
you I find killing things to be so oddly
satisfying like if I was in a kitchen I
would want this to be my sous chef job
like smashing gauger Pentagon I do a
little and then I'd peel it off how
about you you did the jar thing you go
shake shake like you're like you're
turning butter I'll never work for me
when does the Smashing just boom peel
off the rest hell's no no appeal for me
one thing we're gonna do to flip the
script is a tiny bit I'm gonna put a
little bit of our salt on top of these
minnows first because we want to draw
out the moisture
even though Abby Fisher says to do it
last on Abby is watching you right now
I mean she's shaking her head and she's
thinking child I told you at the end
all right tomatoes are done what's our
next step then cut in small pieces two
large pieces of sweet ham and add to the
rest seasoning high with pepper and salt
so is this our sweet ham know what it is
lamb bacon pork yay
well first of all the pork eating
quotient among us is not high between
you and me but also let's not forget
that this dish starts off in a part of
West Africa where people don't even
really eat pork but people improvised
all the time so how are we going to cut
this so we're gonna do like chunks and I
want you to go like this like dice and
yep dice and birds this is lamb bacon so
there really is no proper meat or this
is the way to quote-unquote do it right
this is more like yeah putting the
protein that you have and seasoned
accordingly
exactly let me see so this is lamb bacon
I've never had it how much flavoring
does this bring my god so what are you
getting from them I love the flavor of
the fat itself any little barbecue a
mess it kinda is it's exactly like that
all right so we add these in you know I
have to say I really love the attitude
towards cooking that encourages
improvisation that's one of the most
problematic words in food is
authenticity because that changes from
hour to hour a second a second day to
day that's why we put the salt in first
and our last step cook it for 25 minutes
okay one little problem yeah you gotta
stir that stir it to incorporate Oh
chickens at the bottom gently my god you
know I really kind of forgot we even had
chicken in here not gonna lie mix it
together okay
oh this looks kind of incorporated all
right so now our pot is done yep let's
cover it and cook it for 20 what is the
covering okay um so I'm gonna go out on
a limb here and say we'll be right back
okay would you call it really making
something out of mutton imma let you do
that thank you anyway it's been 25
minutes our food should be done Michael
will you do the honors sure YUM Wow it
is for putting no water in I mean look
at that boil and bubble I'm so shocked
oh my god this smells so good
how's this look to you Michael I mean it
looks good to roll or fold colorful
sound it's it's got a good sound way it
talks it speaks to me it's got a little
good look but really comes down to how
it tastes let's give it a taste okay
[Music]
so here we go our 1881 recipe for
jambalaya hmm hmm I don't really matter
me why I think I think it's delicious
Michael what do you think it's like
smoky flavorful and chicken is really
tender in the salt and the hot pepper
from the fresh tomato Delawares - you
know there's no paprika there's no
garlic there's no onion there's none of
these like flavor agents we usually use
oh my god I don't want the best things
we've ever had on this show
roof row for real for real it was on you
yeah a lot better than I was on you I
was on un cinnamon in it what's right
Hannah Hart thank you who do you think
would win in a cook-off you were Abby
Fisher heard it here first
thanks everybody for watching this video
thank you to Michael for being here if
you want to find more of Michael go and
check out his book the cooking gene or
follow him anywhere online at the
cooking gene jambalaya
jambalaya mrs. Fisher's John Burley was
one of the tastiest recipes we featured
on edible history she was able to get so
much flavor out of a few simple
ingredients and a lot of ingenuity this
recipe shows why jambalaya has stood the
test of time
and to this day remains a staple of
southern cooking